Now that you have a cluster
running it's time to test it out.
You need to make sure everything
is running as it should.
To test the cluster's processing
capability you can run terasort.
Typically you test your cluster
on a terabyte or more data but
since you didn't provision that
much storage you'll do less.
You'll have to type in
some long commands here.
So like before I'll give you
the command so you can copy and paste.
First create a home folder for any data.
Next you'll need to create some
random data for the terasort example.
Teragen writes rows of
random data to a file.
Here are our random data.
Each row is 100 bytes long and
we have 500,000 rows.
So 50 megabytes in total.
Remember this is replicated
across the cluster so
it takes up 150 megabytes
across the three data nodes.
Now run terasort on the data you
generated which will sort the data and
write it to a file sorted data
If the cluster was configured
properly everything should
have run without feeling.
Next, we can measure the input and
output IO speeds with test DFSIO.
This will write in removable
files to and from H.T.
F.S and record the average IO speeds for
these tasks.
Then to read files from disc.
The results are written to
test DFSIO results dot log.
If you want to view them later.